I never respect you respect me 52 Beast
I said The Dark Knight Returns my
opinion is one of the greatest graphic
novels ever released it massively
changed perceptions on Batman at the
time it sentenced so many of the values
that we all true today so it's a good
thing that Frank Miller decided to do
this prequel in completely popular it
was once a time when I viewed Frank
Miller as a god then something happened
at some point in the year 1999 he was
kidnapped killed cloned and replaced
with a being that our call bizarro Frank
bizarro Frank is the George Lucas of
comics the most evil being on the planet
who uses word like [ __ ] and guard down
every guard down [ __ ] second since
then bizarro Frank has moved heaven and
earth to tarnish the legacy of his
original vision we've seen The Dark
Knight strikes again
terrible we've seen Holy Terror [ __ ]
terrible
and now bizarro Frank is set to ravage
his classic The Dark Knight Returns with
this piece of [ __ ]
illustrated by John Romita Jr it tells
the tale of the faithful night that
Jason Todd was murdered but is it
actually any good ha like you need me to
answer that but I will the let's dive
into the Dark Knight Returns The Last
Crusade my first question is what's the
[ __ ] point
when reviewing this I just thought why
does this exist but thirty years we've
known what happened to Jason Todd when
he died and a Seminole story that and
the family we saw the Joker the murder
the Boy Wonder
it's still heralded highly on several
top-ten lists it just seems like a
pointless thing to write a prequel book
about it's more pointless than a broken
pencil it's more pointless than a Bible
at an Isis training camera upon
initially reading The Dark Knight
Returns I never really needed the
backstory as to how Jason died no matter
while right a thought of it could never
match the second sadistic torture I
dreamt up with a Boy Wonder
so I never understood why bizarro Frank
needed to cover it guess it's because
he's god damn Frank god damn Miller he
felt the need to delve into the
backstory but from the author feels like
a huge waste of time
it's been 30 years and there's so much
to cover in the Dark Knight universe I'm
really just baffled as why hit this one
we've seen it done a thousand times
before this is a bigger waste of time
than having a [ __ ] after you've just had
a shower opening on a full page of blue
and red lines it really seems like lazy
Frank Miller is back and full of that
after just reading Holy Terror and
seeing how Frank uses pages of boxes to
kill time I began getting flashbacks he
seems to have transferred his
consciousness into the body of John
Romita Jr and forced him to act out his
will so he doesn't really have to
describe what characters are doing on
one page Wow Frank it makes it really
difficult to tell what's going on
especially for the opening it makes you
question which characters are talking
why you should care you know the normal
problems that you face when trying to
read it George Lucas I mean Frank Miller
story huh The Joker babbles some stuff
about how signs is quackery and how the
maestro's have been fooled before
getting thrown back into Arkham
I'm absolutely no idea what this means
and it just seems pretentious or
pretentiousness sake however Gotham
grieves a collective side relief knowing
that the Clown Prince of Crime is locked
up once more News News News News a motif
of the Dark Knight Returns was it's the
terrible use of news anchors to provide
exposition they rear their head here
again but show no real insight or
thought beyond a plastic cartoon
character one remarks that woman might
be too young to be put in these
dangerous situations but it's just
quickly dropped I don't bring up the
point if you're not gonna deliver on it
that kind of thematic carries on through
the book this is a book in which Jason
Todd gets murdered and rather than set
up several warnings to Batman that he's
acting hugely irresponsible Lazaro Frank
drops the main intrigue of the book and
almost as soon as he can bring it up I
wanted to see people question Batman it
would make him question himself we know
that not long after Jason's murder that
he hung up the cowl but why no one seems
to be angry that he's putting a child in
danger it's not more bad one of the
aspects that I love is that fat Matt it
has a whole beating sense to him he
seems like a broken man he like everyone
in the world has to deal with the fact
that he's not getting any younger
struggles to get up in the morning and
it shows a real vulnerable side to him
he's often painted out in other comic as
an unbeatable vigilante but here he just
seems like crap I don't think he wins a
fight through the entire book and it
really invests you in the character and
paints out the frailty of ambition and
life itself all gonna die there's
nothing we can do about it and there's
nothing after it it's really uplifting
the depth is quickly ruined when we
travel back to Arkham The Joker once
again tells the story this time about a
boy born with a broken neck whose
perspective of the world was different
because he never had a straight view of
things it's intriguing it feels like
it's setting up to deliver a huge punch
line but it doesn't it ends with the
Joker walking off mid-sentence there's a
huge buildup of tension but
release imagine having a character named
the Joker and he never tells a joke
instead he tells the cell but it's so
unfunny they can't think of any
punchline you have to feel like a pretty
big idiot of a writer if he did that
whoever you are I know it's you from the
main part of the book revolves around
Batman taking down poison ivy which
seems weird to like Jam is an adjacent
cod death story the rich men have Gotham
flocked to her wanting to do a bidding
whatever the cost
proper proper BDSM stuff especially
because Batman looks like he's wearing a
[ __ ] mask but I digress only I would
criticize the use of ivy she's a very
supernatural character and the world
that was depicted in the Dark Knight
Returns is very grounded except for
Superman the plant lady doesn't really
belong in this universe but here she
does kind of showcase Batman's impotence
both physically and mentally he's faced
with a beautiful woman and is unable to
properly perform and that's kind of a
metaphor for just how beaten he actually
is it's nice to know that even
metaphorically bizarro Frank still has
its roots in prostitution Robin takes AI
me down Batman barely makes it through
the fight and during this the Joker
escapes Arkham building towards the
conclusion unfortunately the climax is
really depressing and dull Robin takes
off into the night looking for the Joker
Bruce is unable to follow just cuz he's
had the crap kicked out of them he's
like a woman in a 50s
eight kids like like throwing one of
them mini sausages now you get a
Christmas down a train tunnel not
underground either outside you know
proper beat that big that beat but I
digress
Jason foolishly goes to take down the
Clown Prince of Crime and his ambush
beating and then the story ends that's
it it's over just as things were getting
good I know that this was originally
supposed to be a two part of it there's
no follow-up no there's no follow-up
coming because I know how lazy Frank
Miller is
the sequel book has about as much chance
of coming out as Tom Cruise does so I
can only judge this book on his own
merits and not what could be coming down
the line and honestly it's pretty crappy
and a joke that the Joker failed to tell
earlier on in the book this book fails
to deliver on its main selling point
which is Jason Todd's murder it really
feels like it doesn't deliver the
punchline it's all set up to nothing I
wanted something that would rival death
in the family all I got was a death of
my appreciation for the Dark Knight
Returns it adds nothing to the source
material and I wish bizarro
Frank would just leave this property
alone so overall this is a really
disappointing story the artwork is great
and services it very well but I can't
really recommend a story that doesn't
have a proper ending just a beginning a
middle and then there even as much as I
like the original boot perhaps this
trade will be worth collecting of a
sequel ever does come out but a Dalek
will so at the moment I can only give it
a 5 out of 10 so I'm gonna be doing this
a road to the Dark Knight 3 series where
I review every book in the Canon of it
make sure you subscribe my channel
because they're coming next is the dog
Knight Returns and then after that I'm
gonna do that you're the Dark Knight
strikes again and then after that the
Dark Knight 3 and you can check out my
full of thoughts on that on my youtube
channel and my website at definition
Cola UK thanks very much for checking
out my video
take care
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]